yo what's up guys how are you all doing
today I have a very interesting video
which I've only just found out about in
the last few days from a couple friends
and apparently this has been going on
for 8 months and I've never seen a video
on it before don't quote me on that but
this is Wy running so as everyone knows
wyvn are an amazing way of making money
because most of the drops are ala balls
and they sustain the same price now
there's a lot of people who Camp there
void Rangers who can safe spot the Wyn
and they can camp there for as long as
they want and they make up to 500k per
hour amazing range XP and plus it is
fully AFK apart from obviously when you
have to loot the drops now then the
Rangers want to camp there for as long
as possible because they can keep all
the loot in their inventory because most
of it is noted like adamant typ bars
magic logs and battle staffs and they
also drop some Rune items and Earth
battle staffs which they can out and
they can also put the herbs in a herb
sack if they have one however the Wyn
also drop some unnoted drops like pray
potions herbs if they don't have a herb
sack dragon plate legs tooth half of
keys which they can't hold in their
inventory and that is where the Wyn
Runners come in so basically the Wyn
Runners will buy the unnoted drops of
the Wyn Killers for like half the price
because it's much more efficient to sell
it to other players rather than banking
all the loot and they'll make more
profit per hour and the wyvern Runners
will also make a lot of profit so it's a
win-win situation now then there's two
Clan chats which I know about one is
called W queen and the other one is
called W CC with another clan to of w C2
and they're both delighted that making
this video and they just want to build
an amazing Community where people can
chill in the clan and basically they
just want people to make Bank whilst
having fun they're really happy about me
uh putting out this moneymaking method
because they want more people to be
killing the wyvn which means they needs
to be more Runners which means there's
more people making money I'm also going
to leave a link to a Reddit post if you
want a full guide and loads of
information on exactly what it's all
about it's got every single detail down
there that I may have not have mentioned
so go check that out if you want to
learn more information I know this isn't
going to affect prices because literally
all of the drops from Wyn are sustained
because of ALK value so Wyn are always
going to be an amazing Money Maker so
there's plenty of w killers and
basically what they do when they get any
of the following drop if they get a
plate leg drop RAR weed Loop or tooth
half two prayer potions uh dragon Stone
runite bar they'll call it out in the CC
so say if they got two prayer potion
drop they'll say two ptss World 50 so
what the runners would do they go to
world 50 they trade the person now
there's certain locations of where you
meant to trade them you meant to like
trade them behind them so then the Wyn
doesn't attack you you buy the prayer
potions as of now for about 6 to 7K and
obviously they go for 12K you buy them
for 50% of the the price basically you
buy the rner for 4 to 5K and obviously
they go for about 10K so yeah basically
you cut 50% of the price and that's what
you give them in cash so as you see in
the background this is exactly what you
do you can see exactly how it works the
Wy Killers will always call when they
need someone to trade them and they will
always want someone to trade them
because it's not efficient for them to
bank they will make more money camping
there rather than banking also another
thing you can do I bring a few sharks in
my inventory in case anyone needs sharks
cuz they buy them for like 3K each and
also they want range pots as well so
sometimes they'll trade in a prayer pot
for one of your range pots cuz obviously
range pots are only like 5K each there's
actually no requirements for this
obviously I'd recommend a a decent
combat level in case you get attacked by
one of the wyns you shouldn't have much
of a problem because most of the time
they're getting attacked anyway bring an
elemental Shield or a mine Shield I
didn't bring one but I was fine cuz I'm
like Max combat but you don't need 72
Slayer to enter the caves I'd recommend
uh completing the fairy Ring 2 while
I've not even completed it I've just
started it so I can still use the fair
Rings that's the best way to get there
and it's literally as simple as that you
join any of the ccs and you know you let
everyone know that you're running when
you let them know that you're running
you can sometimes add some of the W
killers and you can personally run for
them so other people can't crash you so
you've got a certain amount of people
that you're running for so you don't
have to compete with other people
obviously there's going to be a lot of
competition but I'm not telling everyone
to go run for Wyn I'm telling a lot of
people to to kill them so there's an
equal balance of plenty of people
killing them so then there's plenty of
Runners needed and yeah it's just if you
if you want to make money you want to
AFK you want to get some XP and you want
a good place to socialize then
definitely join with the clan chats cuz
they're just trying to build a good
community and they try to avoid people
crashing so the price per hour you
should be looking to make for the W
Killers using range is about 500k profit
per hour whilst afking whilst getting
that range XP and for the runners it
varies so much because obviously if
there's not many Runners and there's
plenty of w Killers you could make well
up to 2 milph but I'd average this
around 500 to about 1 mil per hour like
realistically so yeah it is amazing and
yeah I just want to say this quickly
about all the moneymaking methods I've
been uploading recently because it's
relevant to me being cleaned obviously
I'm going to get back to the P game very
soon but because I'm cleaned I'm looking
for moneymaking methods and that's why
I'm uploading them obviously they're not
going to be very effective in the first
day two days week two weeks I'm
uploading them because they're always
going to be on YouTube and you can check
out my moneymaking guides from like a
year ago and they will work like these
moneymaking methods will work in a
year's time or a month's time when
everyone's forgotten about them
obviously they're not going to be very
effective in the first week when like
thousands of people are checking them
out so yeah when people say it's ruined
how are you ever meant to upload a
money-making method to YouTube to help
people out it's impossible without
people saying a drein but anyway uh
thanks for watching hope you enjoyed the
video video hope it helps you out and
I'll see you very soon peace
[Music]
[Applause]